voilà cinquante ans après le chanteur de
jazz premier film homologué de
l'histoire du cinéma parlant
le son a atteint une extraordinaire
perfection est désormais fait bon ménage
avec l'image qu'il tyrannise a pourtant
longtemps vos places
attention pas sato 6e
les chiens la 15e et c'est ainsi les
visons les maisons lennar les rennais
est divine
le compte y est à nouveau blessé
l'animal à l'eau par la proue attentive
[Rires]
[Musique]
exécuté en contrechamp sur sur l on peut
passer d'une à l'autre
j'espère toutefois faire un travail en
son direct comme ça où on s'est croisés
donc on fait une scène comme ça la
planche aux directeurs sont directs et
parfois vous êtes obligés de passer
fournissait lorsque c'est un extérieur
entre berthoud gentil pour le film
comique qu'on perd si on veut se donner
l'air bof on peut peut-être un péché 17
faire à une dramatique s'effacer
meilleur parce que nous prônons celui au
jour le communiqué on arrive à prendre
dans matrix 1 quand c'était pas mal je
ne suis si on a réussi à le faire non
pas le résultat peut être aussi bon pour
le spectateur c'est non non non non
boulot comme et c'était difficile parce
qu'ils se passent quantité d'événements
autour d'une prise dock cela qu'il est
très difficile de retrouver la fraîcheur
d'inspiration alors que
le studio bones
et puis après qui la voit son studio
d'enregistrement la possèdent plus l
intonation et les attacher cloud rire
autochtones pas voir le mal de la sans
faille